okay hi everyone i'm sorry i'm slightly
late here
a little bit of technical difficulties
for once
um all right so we are here for another
episode
of uh science and technology q a
for kids and others and we have
a bunch of questions here um
[Music]
and uh oh boy
all kinds of different things being
asked here
um all right so i'll pick um
i'm going to pick different questions
here um
there's a question here about the p
equals np problem
and why is it difficult to solve let me
try and explain
what the p equals np problem is and what
the story with those kinds of things
is so the question is how hard is it to
compute something
so one's used to doing calculations for
example one might be used to doing
calculations by hand
i don't tend to do calculations by hand
i used a computer to do
calculations forever and ever but in
principle
one knows how to do things like multiply
numbers
so let's say you have a number and the
number one two three and you're
multiplying it by four five six
and i have to admit it's a really really
long time since i did long
multiplication myself
but in principle one might remember how
to do long multiplication of one two
three times four five six
and so what you might know
is that you would multiply i think
one digit by all the digits in the other
number
um another digit by all the digits in
the other number so let's imagine that
the number
has uh n digits it has um
uh there's there's n digits and the
numbers so for example one two three
there'll just be three digits
um four five six seven eight nine four
five six seven
eight nine that'd be five digits and so
on okay
so if you try to work out how many
how many multiplications you have to do
to work out that long multiplication
you're taking every digit and one number
let's say both numbers have n digits in
them taking every digit and one number
and every digit in the other number and
you're multiplying each digit and one
number by each digit and the other
number that will take
about n squared operations to do that
okay
so it takes about so to multiply two
n digit numbers roughly as the
size of the numbers gets bigger will
take an amount of time that's
roughly n squared now actually for
example in wolfram language
when when you have digits numbers with a
million digits in them for example
we have much more efficient ways to
multiply those numbers than just
by uh multiplying out each number by
each number and the way those work
more or less is that when you multiply
each digit by each digit
you're actually ending up doing the same
computations many times
um and you can kind of optimize that and
the the actual speed of multiplication
tends to be for those who understand
these kinds of things something like n
log log n um so it's just a little bit
uh
slower than just reading in each digit
which would take about
n steps okay so that's how long it takes
to multiply things
n squared analog n something that that
grows
like like n or like n squared something
like that
okay so when you're multiplying numbers
together that's how long it roughly
takes
now let's ask another question let's say
we're given a number
and we're told that number is actually
two other numbers multiplied together so
for example it might be
a one number might be two prime numbers
two very long prime numbers
multiplied together that might be the
number that we have been given might be
two
big prime numbers multiplied together so
the question then is
can you find what those prime numbers
are so let's say you have a number
and it's a 200 digit number and you're
told
that number is actually 200 digit primes
multiplied together but what which
primes are they
so one way you could tell that is you
just start
dividing the number by a succession of
primes and you say is it this one is it
this one is it this one so for example
if you've given the number 18 and you're
asked to factor that number
so you might say well let's divide 18 by
two okay great
it divides we get two times nine okay
terrific
actually i've chosen a bad example there
let's let's pick um
the number 20 for example okay so we
divide it by two
it divides we get two times ten great
now we have the ten
now the next thing we might try dividing
it by is a three okay does
does three divide into ten no it doesn't
okay let's keep going the next thing we
might try dividing it by is let's say
five
the next prime okay it divides that and
we keep going
so one way we might figure out
whether we can whether this big number
of hours is which prime num which primes
it's it's
multiplied together get that number is
we just try
dividing each successive prime into the
number that we have to see whether it
divides
okay well if we have a number that has
n digits and we ask how many numbers
do we have to divide into that number to
see whether to find out whether
it it they can divide in well okay that
number let's say we wanted to find out
we have a number of size let's say about
a million
and we want to know uh does something
divide into a million well actually
uh roughly we might have to try dividing
numbers that go all the way up to a
million we might have to try dividing
all those numbers and no million in in
base 10
has has seven digits um and
uh so if we were multiplying two
numbers of size about a million it would
take us about seven
squared uh operations to do that but if
we're trying to figure out
uh how to break a million down into its
factors
then that's something that could take us
an amount of time that's not
seven squared but it's actually like
something on the order of of uh a
million or
ten to the power six steps
so in other words the multiplying two
numbers together that's pretty easy
figuring out uh a number that can be
written as
a product of two numbers it's really
hard to figure out what those two
numbers are
and so far as anybody knows there's no
way of figuring out
uh how to in general what the factors of
a number are
in so-called polynomial time that means
that
if you ask can you figure out for for a
number that is
n digits long can you figure out uh the
factors of that number
how long does that take it takes uh
something which is
exponential in that number of digits uh
number of steps to figure that out you
can't figure it out
in something that is uh a polynomial
like n squared or something in the size
of the number so it's something that
that and sorry in the number of digits
in the number it's confusing when i say
size of the number
because there's the actual number itself
like a million and then there's the
number of digits in a million which
might be
seven digits okay so okay so the
the the um uh
there's this way of sort of classifying
problems that computers try to solve
in whether they are polynomial time to
solve whether there's a known program a
known algorithm
that as you increase the size of the
problem as you increase let's say the
number of digits in the number
there's is the difficulty of solving it
something that increases just like a
polynomial like n squared or something
or does it increase exponentially like
two to the n or some such other thing
uh with the size of the problem okay so
that's that story so now what does
np mean so np actually stands for
non-deterministic polynomial time
so what that means is if you could only
guess the answer
you could check that you got it right in
polynomial time so for example for that
factoring problem
you can work out whether the um
uh whether whether you got the right
answer if you have something where you
say
this is a factor of that number then
you'd say
is it in fact correct that it's a factor
of that number well you just have to do
the division and division is something
that it turns out
takes or no let's say let's say you just
you're just told
these are the two factors of the number
you just have to multiply them together
that takes polynomial time to check
so np non-deterministic polynomial time
means it's polynomial time to check it
but it might be much more than
polynomial time to be able to find the
answer in the first place
okay so it's been a big unsolved problem
since the early 1970s
whether the class of problems that can
be checked in polynomial time
uh is whether all problems that can be
checked in polynomial time can also be
solved in polynomial
time the most famous example of that
pair
is multiplying numbers and factoring
numbers and that's that kind of that
the difficulty of factoring numbers
relative to multiplying numbers
is what leads to the standard methods of
public key cryptography
um used to to uh uh do security of
of uh of lots of things on the web and
so on
so the question uh so so
there's been this whole question of uh
so
one of the difficulties in resolving the
p versus np
problem is if you're told well factoring
factoring numbers what's the most
efficient algorithm for factoring
numbers
well if somebody says here's an
algorithm it succeeds in factory numbers
well you know that algorithm can factor
numbers
but to prove that there's no algorithm
that has a certain efficiency that can
factor numbers is really hard
and in fact there are almost no known
methods to prove so-called lower bounds
to prove that there is no way to solve
this problem
faster than such and such a thing uh
actually i
myself have done uh some work that that
gives one some ideas about how this
might
might be set up because actually one of
the things i've been interested in
is let's just say you pick small
programs to solve these problems
and let's just say you pick you just
start enumerating programs you say this
program
then this program and this program just
try every possible program there might
be
a billion programs you might try you try
all those programs
some of those programs most of those
programs won't solve the problem
but some of those problem programs will
solve the problem
and you can then ask how quickly do they
solve the problem and so that gives you
sort of an empirical way to work out
what is the fastest program that solves
this problem and usually what you can do
is you can look at that for a problem of
a very specific size you say
n equals three or something what's the
fastest program that solves the problem
for n equals 3
what's the fastest program that solves
the problem for n equals 4 and so on
and what you'll often find is uh that
you look at the fastest uh program for
doing sort of the polynomial
time thing and okay it bubbles around
and it's it's really quite fast and you
can see that
it is certainly faster than that
polynomial you know it's a it's as fast
as a polynomial
then you look at the np case and you
find well some of those cases for
n equals four well there's no efficient
way that you can find to do it by
enumerating these programs that's really
slow
n equals five well actually there's an
easy way to do that and equals six maybe
it's long and so
this how fast can you do it with
programs that curve kind of bounces
around all over the place
so the p equals np problem has to do
with
when when um uh when the size of the
problem gets large when our n for this
number of digits or whatever gets large
how does polynomial time compare to
non-deterministic polynomial time
that may be a very hard question to
answer because it could be
that the the optimal time for np
problems bounces around all over the
place
and to know at an infinite after for a
an infinitely large problem is it going
to be faster than or slower than
this this thing that represents how fast
polynomial time problems are done
may be really hard to know in fact my
own guess is
that if you really ask about the
infinite case it may be in some sense
infinitely hard to answer that question
um and in fact it may be that that the
standard set up for mathematics that we
have
simply doesn't contain enough
information to be able to answer that
question definitively
so that's a that's a little bit of a
sketch of the the p versus np problem
there's some uh there's a lot more to
say about it actually
uh let me not let me not go into that
it's probably a little bit
overly complicated here um
uh let's see um
oh boy there's a question here um
all right let's take this one uh how
can one solve format's last theorem
okay so there's a little bit of math uh
and i could i could
show you this on the computer but let me
just talk about it
um people probably know the pythagorean
theorem
if you have a right triangle you have
x squared plus y squared x and y are the
two
shorter sides equals z squared the the
um
uh where z is the length of the
hypotenuse okay
so one question is for what whole
numbers
x y and z can x squared plus y squared
equals z squared
so for example 3 squared plus 4 squared
3 squared is 9 4 squared is 16.
okay this is challenging my arithmetic
but 9 plus 16 is 25
and 25 is 5 squared so 3 squared plus 4
squared equals 5 squared
that's an example of what's called a
pythagorean triple
it's a it's a triple three uh
whole numbers that have the property
that x squared plus y squared equals z
squared okay so there are other
pythagorean triples
next one is 5 12 13. 5 squared plus 12
squared equals 13 squared
so in fact there's an infinite number
of pythagorean triples numbers for which
x squared whole numbers for which x
squared plus y squared equals z squared
okay that's all well and good so a long
time ago in the 1600s there was a chap
called
pierre de fermat who was uh
reading a book about number theory about
theory of numbers and equations and so
on
and um there was a uh one of the
questions that came up in that book
was the question of whether for example
x cubed plus y
cubed equals z cubed so x cubed remember
is x times x times x
so for example 2 cubed is 8 3 cubed is
27 and so on
are there whole numbers x y and z such
that x cubed
plus y cubed equals z cubed okay
and uh so the answer seemed to be no
and music wrote in the margin of this
book that he had
um you know i have a proof of this fact
in fact he had a proof of that fact for
all n
x to the n plus y to the n equals e to
the m for all n greater than two
he said i have a proof of the fact that
there are no whole numbers
x y and z that satisfy the equation x
x x to the n plus y to the n equals e to
the n for n greater than two
he said but the proof is too small to
fit in this margin
and then unfortunately mussier fermat i
don't know whether he
he uh you know eventually he died and
uh that book was found and it's like
okay uh well where's the proof
well nobody found a proof that he'd
written and
for about 350 years maybe after that
time
people searched for a proof could they
prove
that there were no whole numbers x y and
z such that x to the n plus y to the n
equals z to the n
and people looked and they tested for n
equals three
you know you try numbers up to a million
for each of the x y and z up to a
billion up to a trillion
and you see are there numbers that match
that for which x to the n plus y to the
n equals e to them nobody found any such
numbers
and people slowly started proving that
for particular values of n
it wasn't possible to find numbers whole
numbers x y and z
such that that would be the case now
the question was could you find a
general proof for arbitrary end that
this was the case
now in fact these equations they go by
the funny name diaphantine equations
equations
that involve integers named after a chap
called diaphantus who lived in the first
century a.d
um and who who studied uh equations
which so usually when you talk about an
equation like a quadratic equation you
know x squared
plus three x plus one equals zero or
something you're asking
for any number x which satisfies
that but these differential equations
are equations where you're requiring
that the solution be an integer
a whole number so okay it turns out
uh different sign equations integer
equations actually much harder to deal
with than equations where you allow an
arbitrary real number or complex number
um and so there are many equations
involving integers which have the
feature that looks like a very harmless
equation
like x cubed plus y cubed plus z cubed
equals 42 that equation okay
allow negative values of x y and z okay
so that equation
nobody knew whether that equation had
solutions until about six months ago
when a kind of worldwide network of
computers that actually we've been
somewhat involved in
managed to crack that problem and found
numbers x
y and z so that x cubed plus y q plus z
cubed equals 42.
um and uh there were big numbers they
were like
12 digit numbers um that and and kind of
the only way that anybody knew to solve
that equation was pretty much
just to try all the possible values of x
y and z and see whether any of them fit
the equation
a little bit it was possible to a little
bit make it more efficient throw out
some numbers say well you don't have to
try even numbers you don't have to try
odd numbers here
you can make it a bit more efficient but
but in the first approximation you kind
of have to try all numbers a little bit
like that problem i was
mentioning to you earlier about
factoring numbers you might have to try
all the numbers
to see which one factors okay so with
different time equations
uh one of the funky things that happened
was
something happened in 1931 uh and so
this is a
the story of godel's theorem and um
so here's the thing so when you do
mathematics
people say well solve this math problem
okay sometimes it's just a question of
computing the answer
you know what is x squared plus y is you
know what is
um 3 squared plus 4 squared okay you
just
work out the answer it's 25. okay but
somebody says to you
is there any x y and z such that x cubed
plus y cubed
equals z cubed that's not something you
can just work out
by uh by trying things because they're
saying is there any
x y and z and you could be any however
large you want
so whenever there's something which
involves sort of infinity whenever you
might have to look
for any number of numbers for instance
then you might in general have to give a
proof
you might not be able to just work it
out just do a computation to see what
the answer is
now sometimes you can do symbolic
computations where you can work out the
answer
because we know that for any x
excuse me for any x something like you
know 2x plus 3x is the same as 5x
that's something we can just work out
symbolically but but in general if you
say
is it true that there exists an x
such that let's say x squared plus y
squared equals z square
x cubed plus y cubed equals e cubed
that's something that in general
you can't answer uh you can't answer by
just doing a computation
you have to give a proof so what what's
the structure of a proof
a proof is sort of a logical deduction
that says you have certain axioms
for example if you're doing geometry you
might have an axiom that says
parallel lines will never cross or you
might have an axiom that says
you know angles add in a certain way or
if you're doing arithmetic you might
have an axiom that says
x plus y is always equal to y plus x
okay so for any area of mathematics
there's a certain set of axioms that
people pick so for arithmetic there's a
certain set of axioms it's a fairly
small list
that includes things like x plus y
equals y plus x
and it includes some uh some slightly
funkier axioms uh the most funky axiom
is a
so induction axiom that says if you can
prove
something for a particular value of n
and you can prove that if it's true for
that
for value n then it's also true for
value n plus one
then it will always be true so okay so
you have these axioms for let's say
arithmetic axioms for geometry whatever
and you say great i've got these axioms
now
any math problem that you feed me you
say
uh well surely i should be able to
figure out that math problem using these
axioms i should be able to
generate a proof that says either
something is true or something that's
not true
and i can sort of build that up by by
putting together you know by applying
these axioms in an appropriate sequence
i can just work out i can
build them up into this proof okay so
that was what people thought
uh around in the early part of the 1900s
a chap called david hilbert was very big
on sort of formulating all of
mathematics
in terms of sort of mechanically working
out given this theorem
this will be how you kind of collect
together a sequence of axioms and
deductions and so on
to work out that theorems that that
theorem and everybody thought this was
going to be great
we're going to have essentially a purely
mechanical way to do mathematics
okay that was all well and good until a
trap called curt gurgle came along in
1931
and uh godel proved this rather
surprising fact
called girdle's theorem that said there
exists
questions that are mathematical
questions
which cannot be answered by using the
axioms
that you have set up for for example
arithmetic
so the particular thing he did was a
little bit funky
he picked the statement this statement
is unprovable
okay so that doesn't sound like a math
statement but what he did was he showed
uh that you could essentially compile
that statement
you could represent the notion of
provability
in terms of you could represent a little
bit like we would make a a program these
days
you could represent that as essentially
something which was a series of steps
that could correspond to a program
and then he showed that essentially you
could compile the statement this
statement is unprovable
into a statement of arithmetic and then
he could
show sort of an inconsistency and the
only way out of that inconsistency was
to say
that that statement was something that
could be stated in terms of arithmetic
but the axiom's arithmetic could never
there's no finite
proof that you could ever give about
that about that result
so okay so godel's theorem i mean what
godel originally did he wrote actually
fairly clear paper although it was very
surprising to people at the time
um and actually what he did although he
didn't really think of it that way he
basically invented the idea of programs
because what he did was he he he he
wanted a way to take
something which was an operation he
wants to do and break it down
into sort of primitives just the way a
computer has to break down a program you
want to do into certain primitives that
let it be executed
and then so that happened in 1931 in
1936
alan turing came along and invented
these things called touring machines
which turn out to be exactly equivalent
to what what
girdle had done he called his things
general recursive functions
um that uh and and that became sort of
the idealization for computing
and that sort of launched the whole idea
of writing programs and things like this
okay but so what did god's theorem show
so girl's theorem showed that there were
things that you could write down in
terms of mathematics
um that were mathematical statements
which the axioms of mathematics couldn't
ever reach
okay but his original thing this
statement is unprovable it's kind of a
weird thing no mathematician would ever
think of
of dealing with that so there was a big
question if you looked at different time
equations these equations involving
integers
was it the case was actually called
hilbert's tenth problem
david hilbert had defined in 1900 a
series of i think 23 problems
about mathematics that he thought would
be important and his tenth problem was
find an algorithm find a procedure to
resolve whether a a particular integer
equation
like x cubed plus y cubed equals z cubed
has solutions or not whether there are
any x y and z that solve that or not
okay so that was hilbert's tenth problem
so for
for about 60 years nobody knew the
answer to hilbert's tenth problem they
didn't know whether there was such an
algorithm
they'd never found an algorithm but they
didn't know whether one existed
and then uh in the early 1960s
a person called julia robinson came
along and she
basically got very close to showing
that it just was impossible to um
uh uh to um to find any such procedure
and then a chat but i certainly met
julia robinson and then a person i know
quite well yuri mattisevic
came along a few years later and and
extended what julia robinson had done
and showed that yes actually if you
looked at these integer equations it was
the case
that like with girdle's theorem it was
just impossible
using the axioms of arithmetic in
general to establish whether a
particular
equation had solutions or not
okay so the question then is uh so so
for example for the equation
x cubed plus y cubed plus z cubed
equals a constant nobody knows
whether for arbitrary constant for an
arbitrary constant there
it's perfectly possible that that
equation simple as it is
could be one where there simply isn't
any way to go from the axioms of
arithmetic
to be able to prove whether it has a
solution or not
what yuri matassaevic did was he found a
really pretty complicated equation in
fact
you almost run out of letters of the
alphabet you know i talked about x y and
z as the
as the variables in this equation in his
equation you almost run out of the
letters the alphabet in in in being able
to specify them you have a very very
complicated equation
which has the property that you can't
establish whether in general it has
solutions or not
uh using the axioms of arithmetic but so
the question then so why am i telling
you all this the reason i'm telling you
this is because
these statements so arithmetic the
axioms of arithmetic let you prove
certain things
about sort of arithmetic type facts so
one of the things that wasn't clear
was whether fermat's last theorem x
cubed plus y
x to the n plus y to the n equals z to
the n whether in fact
that would be a statement about
arithmetic
that would simply not be provable by the
axiom's arithmetic
that it would be a so-called independent
statement about arithmetic
something that the axioms that we know
of arithmetic just don't reach that far
that you could say about that that thing
would be true or not true and it won't
affect any of the ordinary arithmetic we
know
so okay so it wasn't clear then in what
was it the 1990s
a chap called andrew wiles spent a long
time trying to figure out could he prove
fermat's last theorem and one of the big
surprises there was
that you know it sounds like a very
simple
question you know is there x y z is
actually x to the n plus y then equals e
to the n
but it turned out that the mathematics
that was needed to establish that was
incredibly complicated
and it involved a lot of concepts that
have nothing to do with numbers they
have to do with elaborate things about
functions and sets and
all kinds of things like that that go
way beyond sort of just talking about
numbers
so i think the but in the end he was
able to prove that yes it's really true
that for any
n there there is no solution to x to the
n plus y to the n equals z to the n
except for n equals two or n equals one
as well um
but um so you know that
that question for matt's last theorem is
right at the edge of undecidability
right at the edge
of where the axioms of arithmetic just
can't answer that question
but in fact that question was answered
it's a you know multi-hundred page proof
uh it's not completely clear that every
detail of the proof is correct
you know proofs are about sort of
explaining to people why something is
true
sometimes you can make automated proofs
which can explain to a computer why
something is true
and then the computer can check them but
usually it's very hard for a human to
check those proofs
um but uh the um in the case of format's
last theorem it's a very long
complicated proof
um and in fact in the first six months
when the proof came out there was some
bugs found in it and it was a
whole complicated story but that's kind
of the um
uh that's that's a little bit of the the
sort of the story of fermat's last
theorem and the story
of fairly simple questions in
in mathematics that turn out to be
really hard to answer i mean i i'll
mention two others that are very famous
so of prime numbers uh you may know you
know the
primes 2 3 5 7 11
et cetera et cetera et cetera numbers
that can't be divided by by
that can't be divided by any other
number aren't divisible by any other
number
the um uh euclid
had already written down the proof that
they're an infinite number of primes
that the sequence of primes just goes on
forever there's no largest prime
you'll never get to a largest prime okay
so there's some special primes
that are so called twin primes twin
primes are primes that are one
uh that are just two apart so 11 and 13
are twin primes
um it's the next twin prime
[Music]
uh 29 and 31 i think that's the next
twin prime
that right anyway there are twin primes
that are just two apart
okay so it's been an unsolved problem in
mathematics
since the time of euclid in the uh
second century bc i think um that um
uh the um maybe earlier than that um
that um it's been a an unsolved problem
in mathematics whether they're an
infinite number of twin primes nobody
knows
and that's quite possibly a question
which like in google's theorem
like in uromatic say which is proof of
the unsolvability of hobbit stance
problem
might be something that you just can't
prove or disprove
from the standard axioms arithmetic
another one that's even older
that pythagoras wondered about is
whether there are odd perfect numbers so
a perfect number
is a number that's basically equal to
the sum of its divisors plus one
so six for example is uh it's divisors
of two and three
and so it's uh six is two plus three
plus one
so that's a so-called perfect number and
so there are various perfect numbers
let's see what's the next one
[Music]
i have to type it in or i'm not gonna
know um
let's see um uh 28 is the next perfect
number the next perfect number after
that is 496.
the next perfect number after that is
eight one two eight
um and actually there's a big
relationship and the next perfect number
is 33 million 550 thousand
three hundred and thirty six so
all those numbers are even numbers so
pythagoras
fifth century bc wondered are there
could there ever be an odd perfect
number
well we still don't know the answer we
have no idea
whether there it looks like there aren't
any odd perfect numbers we don't know
for sure
so that's a problem that's been an open
problem in mathematics it's kind of the
oldest open problem in mathematics
it's been open for 25 centuries um
and you know maybe it will turn out to
be something that the axioms of
arithmetic
with enough effort some very clever
person will figure out how to show
that they're either can or can't be odd
perfect numbers um or maybe it will turn
out to be something that's independent
of the axiom's arithmetic
and you just can't get a proof of that
okay as a question here
gosh um
so many questions here there's a
question that there's a
by mark here how many hours do do i
spend reading every day you know i'm
really bad at that i have to say i set a
very bad example
because i don't uh you know
i work on lots of kinds of things i get
interested in lots of kinds of questions
i try and answer those questions and i'm
very directed in the sense that i
i have a question i'm trying to answer
then i'll read all kinds of stuff that's
about the question i'm trying to answer
but if you say do i just sit and read
things for the sake of reading them
i don't tend to do that i think i did
that some more when i was younger but i
think i
i'm mostly a very directed reader i
mostly i i find it hard to remember
stuff when i haven't had a reason to
to try and work it out um and like some
things um i don't know whether the
things i mentioned today where
it's always a you know i've been
learning things for for a long time now
and i tend to usually remember
reasonably well things i've learnt
um and so it's sort of fun for me to say
when did i learn that thing i just told
you about and the answer might be
i learned it last month or i learned it
40 years ago
and they all sort of mixed together um
but i don't think that i
am uh um it's um
uh yeah so so that's i'm not a great
example there
um there's a question here actually sort
of related to this
um how does how do i learn something how
do i study things
you know the number one thing for me is
to have a question that i want to answer
that's how i uh that that's how i really
dig into
to to learning things i'm i'm really bad
if it comes to sort of abstractly learn
something or or
you know or like imagine uh kind of
um uh doing an exercise in a book
i i don't find it easy to motivate
myself to do that it's like a million
people have done this before
you know i'm not gonna add anything to
this i i think it's sort of an
egotistical thing that i like to feel
like i'm doing something new and special
um and i've got some question now maybe
you know if i come up with a question
maybe
maybe somebody else has already answered
it um i'll try and look for whether i
can find an answer that somebody else
already has made to that question
and only if i can't find that answer
were like trying to try and dig in
and answer it myself but when it comes
to learning fields i
i've learned lots of fields um i i find
um a few approaches that i
uh somewhat generalizable i mean for
example one approach
is often you know you've got a big field
you're trying to learn it you know
nothing about it
um good strategy often is you find some
standard textbook
textbooks are often well constructed uh
you know successful textbooks tend to be
quite well constructed
a lot of the details of the textbook
probably aren't interesting to you
but in terms of getting a basic idea of
the field the introduction
to the textbook particularly if it's
written by somebody who's a long time
person in that field rather than
somebody who's primarily a textbook
writer um the uh
you know that introduction is often
gives you a good kind of global view
of what's what's the story in that field
and
and i find those quite useful to read to
get some sort of orientation
of what are the landmarks of things i
should care about in that field
usually at the beginning it's like well
there's a lot of stuff and i
you know i don't know anything about any
of these things and it all seems very
overwhelming
and then you know i'll gradually uh
based on whatever problem i'm trying to
solve i'll try and pick a way at oh i
need to know this i need to know that
i wonder how this works sometimes
because i'm kind of spoiled i'll i'll go
actually ask people and maybe i'll
find a sort of world expert in in that
field and go start asking them questions
and and honestly for for anybody i would
say that that
if you've got interesting questions to
ask go ask the experts they'll be okay
or some good fraction of them will be
will be really happy to be asked
a good question it's it's interesting to
be asked a good question
um you know if you don't ask them a
question where you could just look up
the answer in a book or on the web
but if there's a question where you
can't do that you know go ask them
they'll you know probably half the time
at least they'll be like ah
sure that's an interesting question um
the um so so in any case the the thing
that um
you know for me it's like you go and you
try and learn these things and
usually there's a there's a point in
trying to learn some field where it
seems very overwhelming and every new
fact
somebody tells me is something i don't
understand at all and doesn't fit in
with anything i know
and then usually some amount of time
into it
i'll get to the point where i really
feel i have my arms around what's going
on
and then it's kind of a nice feeling
because it's like well every new thing
somebody tells you okay i know how that
fits in with what i already know
and it's kind of my approach to trying
to learn things but i always try to
i try to always make the things i'm
learning concrete i tend to be writing
well from language
code to actually implement the things
i'm learning because that
lets me you know by explaining it to a
computer
i'm explaining it in a way that i don't
get any sort of wiggle room if i don't
understand it
it's not going to be able to understand
and i'm you know and i'd have to go
back and try and understand it better i
mean also uh frankly
explaining it to other people is a good
way to to try to understand things and
that's one of the reasons i like doing
these uh
uh these live streams is because you
guys are asking me questions where
i haven't often thought about those
questions in exactly the way that you're
asking them
and so i get to have to try and think
through how to explain it and i
understand the things a little bit
better
the detailed question here do i prefer
to read on paper on a screen
um um i don't know i i don't mind
flipping through books i like flipping
through books
um i tend to in practice read things
much more on screens than
on paper but but i do like flipping
through books i like the fact
you know one thing that's nice about
books is that there's a certain sort of
finiteness to books i mean if you if you
have
oh do i have one here yes there we go
here new book
this is my um book about my physics
project which is just
now out um and there's sort of a
you know the content of this book you
can find around the web
but there's some something nice to me at
least about the fact that
um the uh um
that i kind of know how big this book is
i kind of know
i'm not going to click on a link and oh
my gosh there's another
500 pages of material underneath there
um
it's uh there's a certain there's a
certain scoping of of the activity that
you get from
from seeing the whole book um
okay let's see uh
there's a question from mark here how
often do i use the book
the lewis and short latin dictionary
that i do happen to have behind me
somewhere there
um doing science is it useful you know i
have to make up names for things
and i often you know how do you make up
a name for something
well you can just make up a name that's
a random word
and sometimes that works although it's
kind of risky
but a much better way to make up a name
for a thing is to use
a word whose roots somehow relate to
things one already knows have a have
something where
sort of the the word has a feeling that
is like some concept that one already
knows
and since a lot of words particularly
technical words come from latin and
greek
it's useful to go look up well what's
the latin or greek version
of such and such a concept because that
gives one that then what gives one the
idea
oh yeah there's this branch of words
over here that
you know i can i can take something
which is sort of comes a little bit
from that word um and and then use it
uh for uh for the concept that i have in
mind here now i have to say
having said that i i haven't always been
successful in coming up with uh
with classical words i mean like for
example recently in our physics project
there are a whole bunch of words
that aren't very classical like branchio
for the space of
quantum uh states of in in branchial
space it's a space of branching it's a
rather non-classical word
or even more sort of strange word the
word rulial
space the space of rules which i you
know one of the things that's
frustrating about
making up names for things is sometimes
uh you spend a really long time trying
to make up a name for something
and um it takes and eventually you get
it but it might take you
you know a really long time and
sometimes you'll come up with a name the
very first thing you say
ends up being the thing that sticks you
know i spend a lot of time
trying to make up names for uh for
functions and more from language
um to try and capture in you know
the the word i don't know fold list or
manipulate or whatever
to to capture in a small typable
length the concept of some particular
computational operation
i view it as being sort of an absolutely
minimal version of poetry i mean in
poetry
you're trying to communicate meaning in
a small number of words in the case of
function names
you get one to three words to
communicate the meaning and you have to
get kind of a meaning
that is something that reminds people of
the right thing
leverages done what they know about
english but yet is not so specific
that they have the wrong idea about what
you might use it for well similarly in
science
uh you have the same kind of issue you
know do you have
a name that um
is very specific or do you have a name
that's a little bit more general so for
example multi-way systems
again a name which i is not very
classical but um
which i made up very quickly sometime in
the early 1990s has been a really good
name for that particular concept that
now we think is
is the origin of quantum mechanics and
things like that but that name is
generic enough
that it just says what it is and the
multi-way systems end up getting applied
to lots of different kinds of things but
it's generic enough that that's not a
problem
if if one could call them sort of
quantum branching states or something
that one's kind of stuck talking about
them you know once they're
very confused oh it's quantum branching
states but i'm using it to describe
biological evolution or something like
that it's it's rather confusing
so i i found it useful to go back to uh
sort of word roots and there are some
books probably even have them behind me
but which are
i have books of word roots and things
like this and i find those at least
useful for some inspiration
um about possible ways to name things
you know there's some things that i've
been trying to name for
years and i just haven't got a good name
for them
i mean one thing that i tried to name
for years probably 20 years
was some uh wolfram language
um in fact i wrote a whole uh post about
uh the effort to name wolfram language
we eventually named it
in a way that's sort of meaningless
because it just has
you know a name on it that isn't a
meaningful name it's not a name that
says
it's a language about representing
things computationally it's just
says it's just sort of a random word
that happens to be
you know my last name but that's that's
just in a sense a random word
um it's um uh so for example
will from alpha another thing which took
a long time to name
and uh again we didn't want to give it a
name that was too specific
you know like you know answer system you
know
or or like you know uh ansabot or i
don't know what it might have been
called but but
um uh well we have long lists of
possible names
but so one thing i've been trying to
name uh and i'd love to get any help i
can get
is the name for the abstract science of
studying the computational universe
and that's what my big book a new kind
of science um
is about and so that field often gets
sort of called
nks uh kind of as a after the acronym
for the book
but i'd really like to find a name that
represents
kind of that process of sort of
exploring
life in the computational universe you
know i i thought about you know cyber
zoology or something but that's not the
right name
it's a weird name um but anyway so i've
been i've been trying to um
uh i've been trying to get um uh trying
to figure that out
for a long time um
lots of interesting questions here one
from alan about some
clouds and water vapor i'd love to
answer that question um
but let's not do that this time i think
i have to come back and do that next
time
um the question here from swsh
about learning new fields i thought
since i've been talking a little bit
about that i'll try and address that
here
question is whether it's better to start
from modern digested materials
or to go back to the original papers in
a field or original documents in a field
when it was just being formulated
that's a very interesting question so
i think it's worth always trying the
original documents
sometimes they had a
notation that's very hard to understand
things have really been streamlined
since but sometimes they said it much
more clearly
than the people who came later and
sometimes what's happened is
that they said something i don't know
um girdle for example said something in
his paper
and at the time it was pretty hard to
understand because it was very fresh and
new
but then subsequently people
built all kinds of stuff on top of that
and so the things that were in there
become much more familiar and then you
can go back and look at the original you
already have some ambient knowledge of
some of the concepts that are in there
and the original is easier to understand
than it was for people back when it was
first produced
so i'm always a believer in trying to go
back to the source materials and often
they're sometimes quite hard to find and
sometimes they've been abridged
shortened
because people thought there was a lot
more detail than you really needed but
it's actually interesting to see those
things
now sometimes some part of the source
material will be will turn out to be
nonsense
some part of what somebody figured out
just wasn't right
um but it's it's i think it's often
interesting to go back there now
sometimes it doesn't work
if you go back to newton's principal and
try and learn calculus from it
forget it it's um uh you know the
notation is very
uh very complicated and an alien
um and and i wouldn't recommend that but
but it's a
you know sometimes there's been
in in a field where in a field which is
where there's been it's been well
textbooked so to speak where it's been
well trafficked with textbooks
there may be sort of well-polished ways
to learn things
sometimes those things have been
corrupted because they've been set up to
be something where they can be sort of
mechanically assessed
and where people are being given things
where they can write exercise about them
and that doesn't necessarily
capture the essence of the ideas um but
it's
uh but that's some uh that's kind of the
um
um uh yeah so so i mean i i think i'm a
big believer and you know sometimes i
i sort of don't end up looking at the
original source material for something
for a long time
because i figure oh i don't know it's in
some other language and it's all kind of
complicated and it's
uh uh you know and it's going to be
complicated notation i can't understand
et cetera et cetera et cetera
and then eventually i go look at it and
i say that's really interesting
probably it's even more interesting once
you understand the field better
because seeing the the kind of what was
easy to figure out early and what was
hard and often
the early documents will have sort of
obsessions with issues they'll be
they'll be worrying about questions that
actually nobody worries about anymore i
mean i think famously you know in
darwin's
um uh you know origin of species
actually his first edition was better
than subsequent editions in many ways
because
in the first edition he just said here's
what i think is true
but by the third edition of something i
think he got to third edition
um he was like professor so-and-so has
made the following objection
and i'm going to answer that here well
actually nobody cares anymore about
professor so-and-so's objection it
turned out to be kind of silly
um but it really damages the flow of
of what darwin was trying to say so
sometimes you'll get these things which
are of their time
you know where there was some ambient
understanding um
and uh that under ambient understanding
had to be sort of cast aside i mean when
i wrote my new kind of science book
um i was very aware of these issues and
so
i tried to avoid i mean i just kind of
said what was true some people didn't
necessarily like that but i just sort of
said what was true
and and did only in the notes at the
back did i kind of say how does it
relate to
things that people have said before and
you know what do you have to sort of
push aside to understand this
um the uh
um that's a funny thing here uh
quoted by push here um from my
late friend marvin minsky apparently he
said about ai research as marvin said
his problem was that if you look at
papers published between 1950 and 1970
they seem to be 10 years ahead of the
ones that you read now there's been lots
of research and it's going backwards
said marvin
well ai was a funny field and marvin had
a funny place in that funny field
um so i uh ai was a field
that went took some took some funny
turns
um but uh um uh
anyway there's some suggestions from
mark here about auto
uh various possible names for for nks
interesting they don't quite make it but
but
interesting i i have played with the
word auto
um or the root auto at great length all
right unfortunately i have to sign off
here because i am uh
uh late for other things but it's always
um it's always great
um uh having a chance to to chat with
you guys
um and uh i hope i'll be able to do this
again
next week um we have our
our big summer school um where we've got
lots of people coming to do projects and
that's my
why one moment during the year i i used
to be a long long time ago i was briefly
a professor
um that's why i like doing this kind of
explanation stuff because i don't get to
do that most of the time
um but a long time ago
when is it now thirty third of a century
ago
i was a professor for a while um i
stopped about a third of a century ago
um but uh every year i have this uh
three week period
when i kind of get to do sort of extreme
professoring with a group of very
talented students
from around the world um and uh that
time is coming up
just now and uh so that always keeps me
rather busy but i'll uh
hope to make some time to to to continue
these some sessions because
i find them fun hope you guys are
enjoying them too
all right well thanks a lot and signing
off now bye-bye